[Music]
foreign
of the after show I'm your host Nikki
Novak and today we are going to be deep
diving into Guardians of the Galaxy vol
3 we're going to be talking about all
the details of the film the questions
the film Left Behind the future of
Marvel all that good stuff but I have to
warn you before we go on any further
this is going to be a spoiler-filled
episode so if you have not seen the film
go back go watch the film and then come
back and join our chat unless you like
it that way you like things spoiled for
yourself
um but I am spoiled because I have one
of my favorite people here to talk I
don't know if we've done one of these in
person but Perry nemeroff the amazing
Perry nemeroff is this is the first one
I've ever done in person in the studio
I've done a bunch virtually yeah but
this is the first time like I've been in
the studio before but this is the first
time I'm doing an after show sitting
here at the table I know it's really not
so different in person and it's so good
and I'm very excited that it's happening
for this one that's why and I know I saw
you I saw you at the premiere and I saw
you after and I was just like oh that
was the greatest thing I've ever seen
like I just had such a good experience
watching it so overall like what was
your what was your take I'm obsessed
with this movie I'm obsessed with this
series within Marvel so when I walked
out of the first Guardians of the Galaxy
in the summer of 2014 like I knew it was
going to be irreverent and different
especially because it was the one of the
first Cosmic experiences we had had in
the MCU but I didn't expect to fall in
love with it as much as I did but I was
sure it became my favorite Marvel movie
turns out still is my favorite MCU movie
of all time this movie though solidified
the fact that without a doubt Guardians
of the Galaxy is my favorite series
within the MCU interesting so smart so
well done a series that does it all very
effective comedy Stellar looking action
where every single set piece in these
movies has a distinct quality to it and
then on top of that
overwhelming emotion yes overwhelming
especially this one overall I absolutely
loved it too like I was just defying all
over the place when I left that now I
did see it again last night I did have a
different Expo oh we talked before we
started rolling I had some strange
things happen in my theater but maybe
we'll get into later I think it's too
much for the top of this episode one of
them feels very like on brand for this
movie in the subject matter yes but also
wrong I'm just gonna save it for later
I'm gonna do let's tease it but I'm
gonna save it for later so yeah so we
both obviously really loved it um
critics they liked it 81 they it's a
fresh score
um I looked at the previous Garden
Guardians
um Rotten Tomato scores and the second
one got an 85 and the first one got a
92.
um but this is the highest audience
score that they've ever had for a film
thus far 95 audience score so audiences
are really loving this film the critics
consensus is a galactic group hug that
might squeeze he's a little too tight on
the heart strings
disagree the final Guardians of the
Galaxy is a loving last hurray for the
mcu's most rag tag family let's talk
about the great stuff that we loved
about this movie I have to start with
I'm tearing up talking about this parent
I don't know why I just got emotional
but this has a sequence that is one of
my favorite sequences in the entire MCU
can you guess I could think of quite a
few because you just said tearing up I
could think of quite a few moments in
this movie where I was tearing up okay
but it wasn't an emotional moment it was
just like affected me like it was just
so amazing that it just gets give me
like another clue here
um well if I tell you the song
no sleep
oh Brooklyn I understand that
I feel like that that particular moment
Mike can so whenever I watch uh one of
the newer Star Wars movies and the march
of the resistance plays I always cry and
it's a big heavy action scene like in
force awakens it's when the X-Wing swoop
in and helping save the day that has a
similar quality where the team comes
together and they're here to save the
day and that can have real emotional
results well it okay I think it took for
a couple of reasons number one it was
shot to look like a one Earth right the
camera placement
was brilliant so I guess me emotional I
got chills up and down my body because I
just remember I just reminds me of
growing up going to movies if somebody
had shown you a scene like that like
that couldn't have been achieved years
ago like we didn't have the technology
we didn't have that kind of aesthetic
like it's just mind-blowing like I've
seen it twice now I still don't know how
they did it it's absolutely stunning the
other thing I love about that particular
sequence and where it hits in the movie
is it's literally one big handoff from
one Guardian to the next showing how
they showing how they shine in fight
scenes as individuals but also
emphasizing the fact that they kind of
have to still be passing the Baton to
one another in order to you know win in
the overall mission to me like that one
fight sequence kind of in cap
encapsulates what they've earned
throughout the entire trillion yeah yeah
and I think it was so just unexpected
when it came in the film it wasn't at
the very end it was sort of two-thirds
of the way through but that's the second
reason I got emotional was that teamwork
and that kind of like it's in the whole
theme of this movie is it's the family
that you create not necessarily the
family that you're born with and that
sort of that Unison so that was my
favorite so many like Wicked shots and
that like as you were talking about it
all I could picture was nebula falling
apart but then coming back together and
then the rocket in the air and then the
camera goes like through and then twists
and then he's in the air and he's just
like oh it's just so good so what was
your well if you had if you had to
choose a favorite moment in a single a
single favorite scene a single favorite
moment
I so it's more it more ties back to my
favorite character of the entire Trilogy
it's nebula it's just really isn't it
incredible where she started in volume
one where like I know they were teeing
up the family stuff with her then yeah
but really she's a pretty
straightforward villain in that movie
with a one-track mind to get back at her
sister to do like her evil things and
then she completely morphs into a
caretaker and a leader and someone who
is trying to build the community that
she didn't have so I think I wrote down
I want to like find the exact line to
not mess it up it was such a beautiful
line I have so many oh my God I have so
many lines written down here
she says I'm gonna lead the city make it
the type of home I never had I think
that was my single favorite line sing
Single favorite moment it's just the
ultimate payoff for a character like her
who's gone on one of the most extreme
journeys of not even all the guardians
but I think of all MCU characters period
and and has basically hit the point
where she's grown enough to I don't know
earn the right to be able to say
something like that and also make me
believe that she could see it through
did you see the things she said about
how she got the voice you probably
already know this that it was Marilyn
Monroe and please and she said that
before did she only released that she
she happened to have said it in my
interview and I'm like that sounds
familiar was that yours oh it might have
been mine yeah she definitely said it in
my interview yes and you know what I
never put that together before that
moment but she said how she was on set
you know like she hadn't really done a
huge movie before and she said that she
just wasn't sort of getting the
character and then James just came up
and gave her a note that was yours
because you said what's the best Note
you ever got yeah
that was an amazing Revelation like I
would never have thought that that's
where she got the voice from but that's
exactly the voice and then she said she
found the character that way so Bravo
she nails that character I feel like
what happens a lot of times with
characters where they're covered in like
exceptional like makeup and and effects
and and prosthetic elements is like
sometimes the actor doesn't get enough
credit for how much is still on their
shoulders like everything about the way
nebula carries herself and the way that
Karen Gillen is able to you know deliver
those lines to because the other thing
about that Arc that I think works really
well is that it's not like she's she's
turned into a completely different
person there's so much of like that rage
and ferocity that she had in the first
film that she still has in volume 3 but
she's using it in a different way yeah
um I'm trying to think of my favorite
character I don't know if it's hard it
really is hard and it's so easy this
time around because of recency bias to
say rocket but I have to be honest
rocket was never like if you would ask
me in the first one who my favorite was
I didn't connect with rocket
so much well I could see that they
earned that connection over the course
of the film yeah and then when you learn
the I mean this was his story and then
you know it was rocket story all along
where we thought it was star-lord's
story all along but really in a sense
James is saying now that it was kind of
Rocket story all along it's another
thing that I well the second you said uh
you brought up Star-Lord and and Peter
Quill the other thing that I thought was
I mean downright and Brilliant in this
movie is how they handle the situation
between Peter Quill and Gamora that is a
complicated relationship to deal with
you have one party where we've been with
him in the release and the relationship
he established and like as a viewer
who's been with this series since the
day it started like I understand his
want and I understand that that Poland
and that desperation to make this Gamora
the Gomorrah he once knew but then also
here is a new character who isn't that
person he can't force her into that box
and the fact that this movie respected
that yeah and managed to push them both
forward in the process is something I
didn't expect a Marvel movie to ever be
able to do well this movie what I loved
about that relationship and you're so
right about that oh there's another
question there were so many ways that
they could have ended Peter Quill's
story in this film and the fact that he
didn't quote unquote get the girl
or not get the girl there was kind of a
hint of I bet we were really fun that
line about we were really fun but I when
I watched it the second time when she
says to him when he she's he says like
don't you think if you opened yourself
up we we could maybe have been together
and she says I don't think so and the
way she says I don't think so I wonder
how many times they they did that take
because it was the Perfect Blend of like
not making him feel bad but being very
direct
them so I could find them uh easily but
this is one of the most powerful lines
in the entire movie Gamora shouts at
Peter what are you so afraid of in
yourself that I need to be something for
you
um
like
how relatable is that like we're
watching a cosmic Marvel movie with with
all of these wild out of out of this
world elements and like
that's something that I feel like almost
every person on the planet can relate to
in one way or another people can you
probably also relate to the fact that I
think especially for people who are
married a long time and they say they
aren't with the person they married that
they change that's kind of Gamora in a
sense like I don't know who you are
anymore I wonder how many people are
going to relate to that aspect that is
so good at like really every everything
he's done especially in recent years
he's able to maintain that that fun that
you would want in a superhero project
but never at the expense of having real
emotional truth in his material and
that's what makes the Guardians movies I
think it's the same the same thing is
true of Peacemaker it makes them
experiences that aren't fleeting Thrills
that are just fun to watch in the moment
but they're things that you think about
and there's all there's also lasting
character investment in them because of
it there is there for sure is and he
obviously wanted to tell
um Rocket's story he said it was his
favorite character for a long time I
have to give a shout out to Sean gun who
does the physical oh my God the motion
capture because the there were so many
shots of I mean Rocket's story which we
should talk about a little bit his story
was so beautifully told but those shots
of him on the operating table where you
see his little body stretched out and
then the first moment where you see him
and he's terrified in the cage and then
when it comes full circle when he visits
and he sees the other little raccoons in
the cage I mean just all of the
physicality of the body and also Bradley
Cooper who voices the character so
brilliantly and that is that's an A plus
voice that's like one of those types of
boys performances that makes me think
you know the Oscars probably needs a
voice acting category because there's a
lot of people that went into making
rocket and bringing him to screen the
way we see him in the final product but
Bradley Cooper gives an exceptional
voice performance he does so what other
moments were your things that you loved
I thought the music I mean we always
know that his music but creep No Sleep
till Brooklyn which we talked about do
you realize eyes from The Flaming Lips
that's another one I loved but then at
the very end and James does love a dance
sequence Dog Days Are Over I like that
um I love that song like I love that he
has the songs are so connected to the
characters and the story it's not just
like oh there's a cool song in a movie
well sometimes it's like it's not just a
cool song in a movie but I wrote down
this is the day because I'm also
obsessed with uh Empire Records and
growing up that's what kind of started
to mold my interest in music so the
second that popped up in this movie I
was brought back to another movie that
used that song really well that I love
dearly and I I don't know I kind of like
that connectivity there yeah and every
time he surprises you like when you
think you sort of he kind of peaked with
the first you know the first couple the
evolution of it is nice too like popular
music through the years I love the
evolution from the the cassette tape to
to now the Zune and you know it's it's
some something that has the the
possibility to evolve in the future
depending I mean not with James gone
obviously but depending on what they do
with these characters and and it's also
an important story element also it is
Peter Quill's influence on all of the
Guardians and that also has a ripple
effect because now with nowhere you see
their influence impacting a whole nother
group of people so I feel like even
though this is the concluding chapter of
this Trilogy and this may be the end of
this particular iteration of the
Guardians
I think the movie does an exceptional
job capping off those stories but also
leaving you with the feeling that their
influence and and the good that they've
done for each other is going to continue
to radiate through the other characters
I think what I really loved about this
too is how star-lord's Journey How It
Was Written
and I think it was Redemption for Peter
Quill because after end game
yeah the punch in the face and James
Gunn has said like he wouldn't
necessarily have done that to him but
Star-Lord can kind of be a bit you know
impulsive a bit impulsive in a bit you
know immature at times and I really
loved Chris Pratt's performance in this
shouldn't be under like it's so it he
makes it look easy and he reminded me
why he's a movie star in this like he
just did such an exceptional job
of he just he was
everything was Pitch Perfect I thought
every scene that he played was Pitch
Perfect but my favorite thing my
favorite thing was the end okay the fact
that they disbanded
and he went back to Earth and saw his
grandfather that moment for me was like
it could have been so easy to end things
with them in nowhere having a dance
sequence and they stay together but the
fact that James made the choice to have
each person say you know what I have a
different path right now was brilliant
you don't often see that and because
maybe on paper it wouldn't really look
like a strong Choice like oh someone has
to die or they have someone has to get
married or someone has to this or that
the fact that he didn't do that and play
into conventions well it's a it's a cool
thing that this Trilogy does in general
because we we've talked about it a lot
here it heavily emphasizes the
importance of a family and finding that
that type of connection and how that
could change you for the better but you
also can't undervalue the importance of
like finding yourself on your own and
being happy with yourself on your own
and sometimes being tied to others can
stifle certain qualities in yourself
like for mantis for mantis I thought had
a great r Mark and my God like Palms
delivery from start to finish it's
always been really great it was just
Next Level material here she interacts
oh I love the two I love together this
is my favorite cat I don't know I would
say Drax I used to say Drax is my
favorite character after Guardians one
and I still do love him and I mean that
that goes back to the idea of literally
every single one of them having arcs I
forget what the line was in the critics
consensus oh no I'm thinking about
something different where um like I feel
like some there were some folks
complaining about the run time and if
they're like could you have shaved
anything down and like my big thing
about that is is no because we do have a
large Ensemble but every single one of
them experienced a meaningful Arc and
transformation in this movie
Drax included the line I think nebula
delivers it to him at the end where you
know she says something to the effect of
like I see who you really are now and
it's not a destroyer you are meant to be
a dad bad I liked when she said you know
when she says
that she thinks he's stupid and he says
you think I'm stupid and then
it makes him forget the switch as an
actor when he made that switch he makes
him forget and then he just goes and he
and the camera doesn't break so you know
he did that all in one take making that
switch it just he's so good he's perfect
he wants to do serious movies but you
know he's very he's very good I mean one
of the last things I had seen him in
that was more serious was knock at the
cabin and I thought it was great in that
yeah I actually thought the film was a
little bit too long
I thought it was a little people talk
about it being bloated so then my
question though would be what would you
have cut out okay
I think the thing with the children in
the cages because number one they did it
in the last Thor where you see these
children in the cages and I don't think
you had the animals in the cages and the
children I don't think you needed both I
think that's where it became you know a
little bit bloated and it didn't really
it wasn't really necessary and people
keep talking about the animal cruelty
but I'm like what about the children and
that to me is more disturbing and it was
very disturbing in the last Thor and I'm
very surprised not that I would ever not
Kevin feige but that he wouldn't say we
did this already okay why are we doing
this again and I feel like
it it just wasn't needed in the
storyline that's when it became a little
bit too I know you're going to count yes
I will so so I'll first point out the
Drax element I I do think that was
drax's moment to shine and if you didn't
have the children and his connection to
them and him stepping up as a
father-like figure it would have it
would have given him no Arc really yeah
unless they had leaned more heavily into
you know how he feels about mantas
leaving but really I think all those
things go hand in hand
I think it was also important because of
the high evolutionaries uh plan and
operation the fact that the high
evolutionary is is an individual who is
so desperate to achieve Perfection with
his experiments that he's willing to
just incinerate batches not care about
the beings that they have become but
literally snap his fingers and make them
go away and then at the end of the movie
you have the Guardians as a family
welcoming a higher batch number with
also where his experiment started with
animals and say like all are welcome
come on that's what nowhere is about
it's about accepting every being for who
they are and the fact that you have such
a different array of beings being
represented in that group right now I
think is important I mean maybe it was
presented though too separately like it
was like the animals were here and then
there was another layer and another beat
where he was now children it's
definitely separate and then it sets up
what's the character's name that it sets
up that she was
and she was in the post-credits scene
where it sets up her story
you could have maybe had somehow Drax
meets her along the way and it almost
becomes that you can't catch him from
the other children and her or her origin
I don't know like on the set on the top
of my head how you would have infused
her into the story but maybe you know
when they go into the other Earth the
other maybe he met her the counter Earth
maybe he meets her there or something it
just felt like it kind of
where things start to feel like there's
too much going on and I did think it was
a little bit long the one other thing I
will say that didn't 100 work for me as
much as I love the Gamora Peter Quill
storyline I feel like and this happened
to her in avatar The Way of water too I
didn't think she had her own story
oh I make sense it felt like it was
through the relationship that you're
seeing their story that's that's fair I
do think I do think of the relationship
winds up being the Catalyst for what she
experiences but I think like the
satisfaction I felt seeing her go back
to the ravagers at the end that was
great like yes I do think that with
Peter being so pushy it it helped her
more wholeheartedly embrace the path
that she knew was right for her while
also being accepting of of this this
unique family that she just met it kind
of like broadened her Horizons a little
bit maybe I was just missing like one
moment or one scene where it wasn't just
about him convincing her him talking
about the relationship because that end
point that you're talking about where
she goes back to the ravagers worked 100
I'm like that's the moment that I was
missing that would have tied the whole
thing together either in the the
beginning or middle of the story where I
didn't see her as an individual going
through something I just saw it sort of
tied in a bow at the end yeah and her
her reaction and her Joy was great but I
didn't feel like I felt her journey
throughout the film it definitely leans
heavy on the Peter thing the the one
other side of it that I really
appreciated that I thought served the
character well was her interactions with
nebula and the fact that you've got
you've got Peter her boyfriend
desperately clinging and like basically
begging her to be the Gamora that he
once knew and loved whereas nebula's
kind of understanding about or maybe not
understanding like I wouldn't I wouldn't
mind more material uh just in terms of
giving her the opportunity to Really
voice how she feels about maybe losing
the sister that she reconnected with
before and how she feels about this
Gamora but they have different feelings
about where Gamora stands and watching
those run parallel to one another I
thought sir Gamora very well that makes
sense yes I'll tell you one Gamora thing
that I didn't like though oh and I
mentioned it before we started rolling
so the only
non-believable moment in this entire
movie to me the one thing that I flagged
that I said that wouldn't happen she's
too smart is when Gamora tries to get
back to the ravagers and Aisha picks up
I'm like like they're talking on a phone
Aisha picks up and Gamora willingly
gives the coordinates having no clue
that you're talking to the Sovereign
Gamora is smarter than that that is one
thing I didn't believe that's so funny
because I noticed that too but I had
forgotten about it until until you
brought it up
um
we I feel like we could go on and on and
on about the things that we love
anything else that you wanted to add
before we move on to sort of like the
future of the few the MCU and where
things are going I'll just say because
we haven't brought up Adam Warlock
Will Poulter is perfect casting in that
role I am not a Comics reader and I feel
it's all it's often important to point
that out but in particular in this case
because even though I'm not a Comics
reader in order to you know prepare and
be somewhat in the know for these movies
I'll usually Google a good deal about
particular characters that are entering
the MCU for the first time and I did
that of course with Adam Warlock even
after doing that though
the Adam Warlock in Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 didn't really line up to
the character the version of the
character that I had read about so that
was a little surprising to me but I
think it worked really well I I
a big a big theme of these movies is
family and the idea of Adam Warlock
essentially being a baby with a moldable
mind who is around all of these people
who could completely reshape the
trajectory uh he is on in this life is
the ideal addition to this particular
story so I loved that I thought the
comedy worked really well and I thought
they earned that that final moment for
him at the end and I also just love him
and Blair I love him too and I think
he's a cat he's a captivating actor I
thought he people did criticize sort of
the disconnect between the character
they knew and what they saw on screen I
don't know enough about the comics to
know the difference but I thought you
know he was teased in the end credits as
being you know one of the new Guardians
and I think he would be somebody I'd be
really excited to see more from but I
also want to shout out the high
evolutionary chikudi awuji he's so good
it was so good and I said this when I
reviewed this film that so much there
are so many villains that you know can
make or break one of these films and wow
Jennifer he was scary and people some
people had a hard time with the fact
that he yelled a lot and I was like you
know what there we've seen a lot of
these
villains quote-unquote villains that
sort of play at the Hannibal Lecter
route where they go very understated
with the evil and it's all internal I
loved seeing the rage I thought he was
so connected to the material if he
wasn't connected to it and such a great
actor I think it wouldn't have worked
well that Ray that rage and loss of
control is sparked by one of his
Creations outsmarting him so I thought
that the smarter and smarter and more
effective in this Mission rocket became
and how that kind of comes out in him
losing his cool I thought that was very
very appropriate did you cry when you oh
my you did I cried quite a few moments
um I mean obviously Lila thiefs and
floor just totally ruined ruins like I I
had a hard time with that the reunion
with the grandfather I cried yeah when
rocket came back to life uh that I
thought that was also a really great I'm
not going to call it a a dream sequence
because I think it's it's kind of like
an interaction that rocket will like
living rocket will always feel within
him but when he has that conversation
with Lila and she's like nope you go
back now
big Pro like sitting in a puddle of
Tears yeah when she when she goes like
this it's not your time yet those
characters were unbelievable I thought
they were great brilliant brilliantly
brilliantly done
um oh my gosh I feel like we could keep
gushing about this I feel like we could
keep gushing for you know for hours
about the film but we have to move
forward this the two post credit scenes
okay I told you how much I love the
ending I love Star-Lord going back to
Earth
I loved
um the moment with the grandfather the
fact that they said Star-Lord will be
back
and here's one thing I'll just point out
before I ask you a question
I loved I was convinced when I saw this
movie I thought Star-Lord was dead
because everybody because they had had
the European Premiere before we saw the
premiere yeah and everybody kept talking
about how emotional this film was and
I'm like okay somebody dies and he gets
pushed out like gravity style into space
and his face Oh I thought that was it I
thought that was it I'm like oh here it
is they're killing him and James Gunn
wants to bring him to DC and he's gonna
make sure he kills Star-Lord
back
um I was like I don't think he would do
that on purpose but no I thought that
was the moment by the way I met the
makeup artist his personal makeup artist
at the premiere and told me that that
blow that face bloat was practical that
James Wanted everything practical all
right well that that was something that
I appreciated about the movie in general
whether whether it was
um you know individuals on counter Earth
some of the ravagers so like there were
a lot of effects involved but so many of
them were practically done and I'm I'm
like a Reach Out And Touch a kind of
person that's that's how I like that
stuff there are incredible visual
effects artists I would never uh I would
never knock down the quality of their
work but I do really love practical
creatures and he uses both effectively
and I don't know he wanted to shoot a
lot of it both ways but so what did you
think about the fact that they're
teasing yeah do you think like is he
gonna take all the time you know like
the Tony Stark mantle like that is gonna
it's hard to say right that is not what
I would have thought going into the film
film but when I think about the journey
that Peter has been on and what that
Journey looks like at least in my theory
brain going forward I wouldn't be
surprised if that's some sort of path
that he's on because like even though he
he handed the Reigns over to Rocket at
the end of the film like he has been a
somewhat effective leader who who
brought these individuals together to
form an unexpected family that they
never in their Wildest Dreams thought
they could benefit from and he you know
he was kind of the the conductor of all
of that
but I I think he has also been a
character who's been quite selfish along
the way too and and I think that
selfishness does come out in Infinity
War when he ruins the plan by punching
Thanos because you know he has a
knee-jerk reaction and his heart is
broken and he loses his cool I feel like
his time on Earth with his grandfather
and finding himself is what's going to
make him the best leader he could
possibly be and that could mean
graduating from you know not that the
Guardians is a lesser group a smaller
group like the Guardians to maybe being
you know a real leadership Force within
the Avengers going forward so I can see
that happening and what did you think
about the how all the rest of the
characters sort of finish their story
I'm very happy with that I am so excited
to see I'm I was very very worried that
the end of the movie would have more
finality about the Guardians overall
like I know these there were quotes out
there that said this iteration of the
Guardians was coming to a close but
there were also so many people out there
who phrased it like the Guardians is
over yes and I loved clearly I love the
Guardians and I didn't want them to be
over but I love the idea of a new
iteration of the group forming and of
the let's call them Legacy characters
taking the things they've learned and
passing them down to newer Guardians who
then could pass it down to another
generation and that's also the point
we're at with the MCU now I mean look at
look at the future look at the Marvels
you have three characters that have
entered the MCU at different points in
their life one of which is one of the
younger crew who could probably take
this franchise 10 years into the future
that's what's happening right now yeah
are you hopeful for that film so the
Marvels yeah oh my God yeah I love the
three of them I love those three
characters and I thought that teaser was
really effective in terms of selling
that scenario really emphasizing the
value of the comedy in it but also
suggesting that you know it is an
opportunity for three Unique Individuals
to learn from one another and I don't
know if my feelings about Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 says anything I like
story lines like that yeah and I think
it feels like the timing feels right for
that film like I feel like I've missed
Brie Larson's character I feel like I
haven't seen her in so long that I want
to see more of that story and that's
just yeah
like she deserves some time in the
spotlight yeah and I'm from the teaser
it almost looks like she's the lead if
there is one it almost looks like
they've it's it's flipped a little bit
yeah and there's also kittens they it
makes you very happy so um let's talk
about the second post-credits scene that
sort of teases like this this new you
know with rocket as the leader we have
Groot that you know is a little bit
bigger Adam Warlock
um craglin craglin
Sean Gunn
um from first mate to being on the
poster and Guardians of the Galaxy 3 to
being a full one member and being the
brother Cosmo the speed dog
let me take that back I mean he's
probably a space dog played by Maria
bakalova I just I just know the dog as
Cosmo and bad dog no she's a good dog
she's a good dog she's a bad dog she's a
good dog I didn't even realize that was
her yeah by the way I had seen her at
the premiere and then I I it was lost on
me because so many people are in
Prosthetics and yeah I love her work in
general so whenever she gets cast in
something I kind of file it away yeah I
know but I thought that was a fun ending
I thought you know what it it actually
made me excited for what's to come it
didn't necessarily say for sure that
that's where they're gonna go with it as
we know with a lot of these end credit
scenes that well they tease things and
you know and then we're waiting a long
time we don't necessarily know that
that's going to happen but I thought it
was clever I I thought it was really a
effective and that's that's what I want
I want the Guardians to continue I want
these you know I want these types of
characters these spaces that James Gunn
has been able to play in which are I
don't know just like really vibrant and
exciting to me and they're unique from
all the other elements that we have in
the MCU right now I want them to
continue
this is probably very close-minded of me
to say but I have become so used to
James Gunn's Guardians instead and it's
it's also it is a very specific kind of
Storytelling he has a very unique
filmmaker in general I'm not saying that
there is no filmmaker on the planet able
to do what he has done and he is the one
and only and that's the end I think
there are probably very capable people
out there but when it come when it comes
to something being in such unique hands
for so long there's there's a little
nervousness that comes with the thought
of if we do continue with guardians the
Baton needing to be passed from a unique
author like like James Gunn to to
someone else and you know for all I know
they'll announce something and that
someone else will really excite me I
completely changed my tune on the matter
but at this point in time I'm excited
but a little nervous it almost mirrors
like James going over to DC and creating
something new and having the Reigns been
given to you know passed over to
somebody else and seeing what they're
creating so hopefully yeah I I was
thinking about it this morning and I was
thinking oh yeah but he's not going to
be doing it that's right which thing
because it would be really cool to see
what he did with those characters and
how he would build them I'm I've been
trying to think of uh of another
filmmaker that he could maybe
he could maybe bring in or recommend for
the job and but I think that's the key I
think the key is to bring somebody who's
passionate about the material and not
just somebody who's a great filmmaker
who like let's give them this yeah it
would have to be somebody that he almost
you know hands the keys to the kingdom
too and says this is the person which I
don't know who that would be
I mean maybe it's because everything
everywhere all at once is fresh on my
mind but the Daniels feel like the type
of filmmakers who could do anything oh
my gosh could you imagine
I mean I kind of could imagine
I could too
I feel like you don't make a movie like
everything everywhere all at once and
then have the answer to the question can
you imagine ever be no like no matter
what it is it would be so incredibly
creative and unique and
I asked them in an interview if they
ever did a Marvel movie what they would
do like what storyline they'd like to
focus on and they said they wanted to
Kevin feige's story and that he's trying
to get his daughter like you know help
her with her homework and that kind of
thing they're like we want to tell Kevin
foggy's like origin story I mean they
don't want to tell a superhero movie
story they're like we're done with it
it's not a bad idea I know there's like
some sort of like now I'm going too far
down this rabbit hole but there's some
sort of really cool idea with having it
be a very like like grounded filmmaker
origin story that takes place in this
reality as we know it and then having
and everything everywhere element where
like the MCU bleeds into his reality yes
that I want that tuna I want that too
because that's actually a really good
idea Harry
you're the best you're the best thank
you for joining thanks for having this
conversation with me about this movie
that we love so much more more in the
future please
um tell everybody where they can find
you oh wow um everywhere you can find me
hosting collider ladies night which is
my baby I adore it it's on the collider
extras YouTube channel Twitter Instagram
pin emeroff on Tick Tock I'm obsessed
with Tick Tock Perry number of over
there well thank you again and thank you
for watching we hope you guys enjoyed
this uh spoiler-filled discussion of
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3. see I'm
tearing up again and I'm going to end on
what happened to me in the movie theater
last night and that is very in keeping
with this movie a mouse ran over my lap
in the middle of the movie yeah a mouse
ran over my lap
and that's where we're gonna end it
thanks for joining everybody we'll see
you next time on the after show bye
[Music]